hello and welcome back to the shaky
science show so in today's video we're
going to look at the question is calorie
restriction legit so to help break this
question down I will split this video
into four different sections so firstly
I'll give a definition of what is
calorie restriction then we'll look at
what I mean when I say legit for what
and then we'll look at the evidence so
far for calorie restriction and animal
models and in humans and their effects
so firstly a definition so one
definition for calorie restriction is
the chronic reduction of total calorie
intake without malnutrition the
importance being without malnutrition so
the point is that calorie restriction
isn't just naughty thing it's about
reducing food intake by around 20 to 40
percent and it doesn't mean just eating
salads it's still important to maintain
a balance of different foods components
and so this is where calorie restriction
may differ from another phrase known as
dietary restriction where you might
restrict just one component of the diet
such as fat or protein so calorie
restriction kind of comes underneath
dietary restriction but they aren't
quite the same thing at least not by
definition so why are we even talking
about calorie restriction what is the
point of this video so firstly calorie
restriction is a mechanism to facilitate
weight loss which as you can probably
guess is due to the fact that you're
reducing the calorie intake see the
energy intake so that the balance
changes so that's you are going to lose
weight secondly calorie restriction has
been shown to improve metabolic
biomarkers and I'll go into more detail
about that later because it kind of ties
into the last legit association of
calorie restriction which is the ability
to prolong lifespan so is this really
the case well there is evidence to
support that calorie restriction extends
lifespan in all model organism
especially far so that's not quite the
case it extends lifespan and most not
quite all but this has been shown in
different modern organisms ranging from
yeast worms flies and in mice and so in
some cases calorie restriction has been
shown to enhance helps
as opposed to lifespan and the extent to
which you get these improvements also
varies depending on the extent of the
restriction and depending on the
organism and so there's just many
variables to take into account but I
guess the key question is why why with
calorie restriction help to either
enhance health span or to extend
lifespan so the best way to illustrate
this is to go back to the hallmarks of
Aging which I explains in a previous
video and I'll put the description up
and so based on a wide range of both
genetic and biochemical evidence it
seems that high nutrient signaling
stimulates or increases the rates of
protein lipid and DNA damage and the
antagonistic hallmarks that all respond
to increase the process of Aging whereas
calorie restriction inevitably prevents
high nutrient signaling and therefore
doesn't increase this rate of Aging and
so that's the premise behind linking
calorie restriction to enhancements in
both health span and lifespan and so
that video on the hallmarks of aging
will give a better insights into these
different mechanisms but to briefly
summarize and give a more mechanistic
underpinning to this increased aging
rates having a high or normal nutrient
nutrition increases the activity of
proteins called igf-1 and M tall and
also the mitochondrial activity and it
also has the effect of reducing the
activity of ampk and statins and these
are both connected in a process called
otology and so they get the crease and
so the rate of Audiology also decreases
and so as otology is the cell's
recycling system and effectively removes
this functional proteins aggregates
organelles therein so if otology
decreases then you're not going to be
able to remove these aggregates into
this functional protein and hence you're
more likely to increase damage in the
cell and this all in all kind of leads
to aging and so further evidence for
linking these different pathways to help
span and calorie restriction is when
calorie restriction has been combined in
animal models
with inhibition of other proteins so
take em tall for instance when I'm
Taurus inhibited by itself you often see
an increase in the how span and lifespan
of the different model organisms yes
when it's combined with calorie
restriction as has been seen in yeast
and worms
there is no enhanced effect and in fact
this seems to suggest that the two
mechanisms are acting through the same
pathway one of which could be tautology
so now for the bit that you're probably
here for calorie restriction in humans
so firstly just a disclaimer I'm not
here to try to promote calorie
restriction or to say that this is
something that we should all be doing
I don't do it personally I'm just here
to discuss and illustrate the evidence
so far for calorie restrictions and the
impact that has in humans
firstly because there may be medical
reasons or other reasons why it's an
unsafe thing to just jump into and
secondly because a lot of the evidences
still come from and Mosel organisms
annalee model organisms aren't the same
as humans nonetheless studies have been
done in humans and so this paper here
has the results for a two-year study
where calorie restriction was carried
out in young and middle-aged non obese
men and women and say the name of the
study was calorie um for comprehensive
assessments of long-term effects of
reducing intake of energy I am a fan of
the name so what they see after 24
months so at the end of the study they
saw that there was a reduction in
fasting insulin levels body temperature
resting energy expenditure oxidative
stress and circulating levels of TNF
alpha which is linked with causing
inflammation in the body and so these
are kind of hallmarks that's are
correlate with a longer house span as
has been seen in different model
organisms but going back to my
disclaimer whether calorie restriction
extends lifespan in humans will probably
never be sermons in randomized clinical
trials and so the point of studies like
this one is to just assess the
feasibility the safety and potential in
that this could have and as a potential
therapy or treatment for different
diseases and so it's not me recommending
that you do this right now and in
addition to using calorie restriction
potentially in therapy in the future
another study came out literally just
the other day about using alternate day
fasting which along with intermittent
fasting and I really have a kind of five
- fasting
friends so the Sailor calls other
moments are also being studied to see
how that can alter metabolic biomarkers
in the body that can give an indication
of surpassing different diseases and so
this video was you know to introduce you
to where we are currently at with
understanding calorie restriction and
its potential benefits for the body but
it's by no means telling you right now
to do it
so with that thanks for listening